(hip hop music)
- What's up everybody?
It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
I'm here in
Chattanooga, Tennessee.
Home of one of VaynerMedia's
five offices and when you
compare it to New York, LA,
San Francisco and London
I think it speaks volumes
to my belief, our collective
belief of what's going on
here in Chattanooga.
We're standing outside the
Tomorrow Building, that's why
making this random
video with the DRock today.
- [Gary on Gary's Phone]
Everybody has time.
Stop watching--
Stop watching fucking "Lost."
- I love it.
I saw it.
Show it to everybody.
DRock, make sure
that edit makes it.
So that's what's going on.
Alright, cool.
So that's the little update.
Ooh, tell Jordan
has lots of fans.
Jordan, how about that?
- Love you guys.
(DRock and Jordan laughing)
- Double peace sign.
(laughter)
I mean that made what up look
like the most
gangster shit ever.
This is great, right?
Musical.ly's on fire.
I've read zero books this year.
I've read like
seven books in my life.
So I don't read.
I tell people that I'm half
GaryVee and half DJ Khaled and
launched a social
media marketing business.
OTD Mike if you're half me and
half DJ Khaled you're one of the
great human beings of all
time so I'm looking forward to
watching you
ascend to greatness.
(light music)
Hill, what's cooking?
No, this one's
unbelievably better.
I want you to look at it.
You're 100% right.
On the other side when people
take that literally what ends up
happening is we have the most
inefficient machine, we have
three cooks in the kitchen, we
waste money and time so that's
why getting kind of a telepathic
understanding between leaders on
business is the Holy Grail.
What up Snapchat?
I'm fired up.
DRock is here.
Focused as fuck. You?
(light music)
That's what we do for a living.
We sell time, right?
So we're going there, we're
coming back, we're going to do
the thinking and then I come
with you guys to Kansas City and
we present for two, three
hours and then I give a talk
and that's what the
kind of scope is,
you know, and then that's it.
You know?
- Have a good rest
of the day, guys.
- [Gary and DRock]
Thank you.
- [Jordan] You too.
- What's up Alabama?
- [Man] Sayin' that
one more time?
- This is the coolest
shit I've ever seen.
Did you just literally, did
you literally just think it was
going to be okay?
I'm really trying to
understand, you know?
So what's happening?
What am I doing?
Am I doing a keynote?
Am I doing Q-and-A with you?
- #AskGaryVee.
- Love it.
- I'm asking the
first 60 minutes,
audience participation
the last 30.
- I don't want to
see a single question.
I'm so pumped.
- Beautiful.
- Awesome.
- That's all I want to do.
It makes it so much,
it's such a better,
first of all,
it's a better product.
They can see it, if you put me
out their normal they could
watch that shit on YouTube,
now it's all going
to be new shit.
And then we can get you a lot
of exposure because we'll use it
and then everybody's going to
want to come to this and it's
going to be interesting for my
fan base because it's going to
be new shit plus is it
brands you the whole thing.
- [Man 2] (inaudible)
- Mazel Tov.
I'll come back.
- [Robert] Hey!
What's up, man?
- [Gary] How are you, brother?
- I warmed them up for you.
- I feel like you crushed it.
Looking forward to spending
some time with you later.
- Yeah.
- It should be fun.
- So you're going to
face Josh right here and
just show me some personality.
You can take the mic--
- I'm keeping the mic.
- Alright.
(laughter)
- [Josh] Three, two.
- Yeah, anything.
So pumped to connect with you.
- Absolutely. Nice to
meet you too, man.
- Congrats. Nice to
- We'll connect.
- Real pleasure,
see you guys later.
Ready?
- Here in Birmingham.
- It's great to be here.
Thanks for having me.
- Gary Vaynerchuk, packed house.
- It's really cool.
(applause and cheers)
- Robin Hunt Big Data Solutions:
Technology changes so much.
There's always a learning curve,
how do you self scout,
self teach yourself to be
ahead of that curve?
- By doing it.
Meaning I just do it.
You know, like we know that
Pokémon Go is happening.
Right? We know it's
happening right now.
You could say it is a fad or
it's stupid or who cares, I need
to understand it not because
I care if Pokémon Go will be
here in three years but because
this is the coming-out
party for AR, right?
A million apps are being
developed right now, literally
all of Silicon Valley is sitting
in boardrooms right now
creating their AR app.
And we're all going to shop and
go to football games and do all
sorts of stuff
through that environment.
There's people in there that are
never going to do anything
with Pokémon Go.
That's fine but you're going to
do something with AR and
so you need to use it.
It's like trying to run a
marathon without
prepping for it.
You're gonna lose.
- I think one of the reasons
that people respect you and
follow you as a leader is
because you are a practitioner.
- Yeah. I stand in front of
those 500 or so 25-year-olds
and I'm like, "I'm the best at
social media in this office,"
right? And I mean it.
And that's because
I use it more than they do.
They're using it to hook up,
I'm trying to sell shit.
(laughter and applause)
You know, IQ is decreased
in value because
of technology but EQ
is greater than ever.
Emotional intelligence
really really matters.
And I look for that in anybody
that I surround myself with.
Do you actually have empathy and
gratitude and self-awareness and
care and all these warm and
fuzzy things that I think are
the essential infrastructure
to be successful in business?
- Want other people to be
other fans of humanity as well?
- I'm gonna struggle to the day
I die of allowing yourself to
look at glass half empty.
I just feel like,
now I understand it's DNA
and it's wiring.
If you grew up with a mother
who's extremely negative
it's a really tough
situation to break out of.
It's just proven,
I've understood.
You grow up in a
tough town, I get it.
There's a couple of
issues with that.
Number one nobody cares.
That's the big punchline.
- Do you ever get down?
What gets you down?
- As long as the 8 to 12 core
people in my life are healthy
I struggle to really get down.
I just don't know how to do it.
So when you live your life
that way losing a big account or
somebody calling you out
is just not that painful.
You just put into context.
I usually just like, take it.
You know,
this is so interesting,
I think you'll find
this interesting.
My favorite scene in movies is
always when somebody gets punched
in the mouth and they take the
punch, they spit their tooth out
and then they look
back at the other person.
I don't know you seen that.
There's always some
version of that scene.
That's who I am as a
fucking human being.
I'm built to get punched in the
mouth, I'm gonna spit my front
tooth out and I'm a look right
back at you and be like,
"Now what, bitch?"
(laughter)
Thank you, thank you
so much, man.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you, brother.
The posters are back here?
- [Man 2] Yeah.
This is something
that I'm very used to.
- [Man 2] He's like a monster,
like a man on a mission.
- [Man 3] I bet you sign
your taxes like this too, huh?
- [Gary] I do.
That felt great.
You know what I
most excited about?
I really think that's one of the
better keynotes I've given so
that's going to get a lot of
views over the next five years
for you guys.
- Proud of you.
- Thank you, brother.
- Follow him.
- Alright.
- I want you to check it out.
- I will, what is it?
- Card's in there.
- Can I sign it or something?
- Yeah.
- I will my man.
Where you from?
- Here, Birmingham.
- I love it man. DRock.
Thank you, brother.
- [Man 4] Three, two.
- Hey, how are you?
My pleasure, man.
Thank you, brother.
- Mind if I get a pic?
- Hell yeah.
How are you?
- I'm well.
I respect your
time five seconds--
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- This was supposed
to be on a sweater.
Amazon pissed me off.
- I love it!
- If you don't like it,
I can get it to you.
- This is unbelievable.
That's amazing.
Thank you very much.
- Tell Stacy Colin said
get the fuck to work.
- Stacy, it's time
to fucking work.
Let's do this.
One life, Stacy, one life.
Love you, brother.
- Good to see you.
- Good to see you, man.
Thanks for coming out.
- Appreciate it.
- Is that right?
Awesome, man.
Thank you.
- I went eBay shopping
for everything we
thought you might like.
- This is unbelievable.
- Patrick Ewing Space Jam.
- I love Patrick Ewing so much.
You guys are unbelievable
Al Toon, Patrick Ewing.
Thank you, man.
No worries, what's
your name? Clay?
- Thank you Cara.
Take care.
- Can I just give the day that
you're going to buy the Jets?
- Just put the day?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, just put that in there?
What is it now? 2016?
- [Man 5] Yep.
- 2016, 2041.
Take care, man.
Thank you.
Really nice to meet you.
Time to go?
(light music)
You need to come
to them and say,
"Look, I need to know
you because then
"I can make it
better for you."
So some people
want you to rah-rah.
- I'm going to look
straight ahead and be
like a fucking idiot.
- But you know and listen, I know
you know even better than I do
from a technical standpoint.
- All those companies just
got fired up because of it.
- Half of, like I said in there,
half of fucking Silicon Valley
right now is sitting out
and white boarding their AR.
- This is why I'm so
happy I'm sitting here.
- Bunch of knockoffs.
- Bunch of shit.
But, but, and you know this and
this happened with social,
for every Snapchat and Facebook
there was plenty of Plurks,
there was plenty.
So you're right there'll be
plenty of shit but there's some
fucking 17-year-old bad ass who
is thinking I'm going to build
the next Snapchat and now what
he's gonna do is to use this and
build something meaningful.
- The guys who build
upload we born in 1990.
- I know. Right?
- You're right.
- Our business development
manager was born in 1996.
He's 19 years old.
- We're the oldest
guys in any company.
- I launched
WineLibrary.com in '96.
Kid was born.
Yeah, it's a new world.
They need to see you you,
they need to see you,
they need to see
you go and execute
build it from here to the
next level then it feels real so
everybody in this community
needs to help each other because
if one player wins in this
market all of you are
going to be impacted.
- And that's a thing is many of
these markets weren't
Silicon Valley until somebody
plowed and tilled the land and
made it happen.
- 100%.
(light music)
- [Woman] Really?
- [Gary] This is nice.
Oh, I'm sorry.
- It's a gorgeous view too.
- It's nice.
I'm in a funny spot.
I'm trying to analyze.
Obviously, I've made a real
commitment in
Chattanooga, Tennessee and
obviously it's very close
to here but like VaynerSports,
I could see maybe even
opening, I want to really
get to know this tech community
and I want to get to know you
because this is the kind of
place where I could see opening
a VaynerSports office because
let's call it what it is.
- Talking about
this environment.
- [Gary] In the same way that
I had to go to Silicon Valley to
meet Scoble and all those guys
when I decided to go into tech,
if I'm going to be recruiting
college football players
this is fucking,--
- [Man 5] Yeah.
- this is the capital.
I'm going to change the game.
- I believe it.
- I know you do 'cause
you know enough about what,
this is what I do.
So I'm very excited because you
know wine I loved because it was
the vehicle for my
business passion.
Marketing I love but AJ, my
brother, said the best thing.
He said I just talked to him the
other day I go, "So what do you
"think about this
VaynerSports thing?"
He goes, "It's a lot more fun to
sell a 6-foot-2 safety than it
"is a bottle of water."
I think it comes down to my big
thing is you got to be
paying attention.
(chatter)
You have to be present.
And you have to be
present in a lot of ways.
Not just physically,
I think it's mental more
than anything else.
I speak to my kids a lot.
I have far less time
I think than most people.
It's unbelievable how
much I talk to them.
It's because I'm so, I have a
flaw which is wherever
I am is where I am.
- [Man 7] 100%
- It's why you guys
like it so much.
But it comes at the
expense of at home.
On the flip side, when I'm
home I am not locked into this.
Right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's just real.
There's nothing else going on
in the world right now
than the eight of you.
- [Gary] You know what, guys?
I want to say
something right now.
Getting a little bit
on a bigger plane.
What's happening right now
is the small minority of people
that are mad and angry and
hateful and dark are
much louder than the
big percentage of us
that are happy and
excited and feel great.
And because the
way technology works
they are much louder than
they've ever been before.
If you leave with anything,
for any of us
please, please take on this
sense of responsibility
that if you've got good
and you feel good
to start sharing that
content as well
because the world
needs more of it.
(hip hop music)
- [Driver] Bye Gary.
Have a safe trip.
- Thank you, darlin'.
Good day.
Good.
Birmingham,
Alabama.
(hip hop music)